bringen wir natürlich immer ein bisschen
die leute mir war kann ich meine lieben
willibald und herzlich willkommen zu
einem gameplay video von roth redemption
ich habe mir gedacht ich zog das ganze
spiel einfach malen ich habe es auf
youtube entdeckt und hab mir grad
das sind witzig auslösen könnte mir
gefallen ich habe schon ein bisschen
gespielt wir werden jetzt allerdings mal
meine player data zurücksetzen
also ihr seht schon ich spiele das ganze
hier mit meinem xbox controller ja alles
so ich werde jetzt einfach mal hier die
options gehen und das ganze hier reset
player data jetzt also ich hab keine
xbox heute das denkt aber ich habe
einfach hier so einen pci controller das
mit egal kann man auf jeden fall mit
controller und mit tastatur spielen wenn
ihr eventueller wollte sich dass mit
ihnen im anderen youtuber hier bei mir
mit dann doppel face cam und so für zwei
leute drin sind mit zwei controllern
spielt dann zeigt man mit einer
bewertung oder schreibt meine kommentare
wie ihr wollt
wenn du da andré den hab ich weiß auf
jeden fall cool es geht grob gesagt
darum dass man als erster ein ziel muss
so wie bei jedem rennen spiel allerdings
ist das hier ein wenig brutaler man hat
waffen man kann leute abschießen die von
ihrem motorrad unterschlagen und wenn
man irgendwo gegen fährt dann kann schon
mal sein dass man total hoch fliegt und
dann hat sich total nett aber der sinn
des spiels es einfach das als erste das
rennen zu beenden ganz viel geld
einzusammeln und man kann sich von dem
geld erhalten neue sachen kaufen wie
beispielsweise grad schon gesagt waffen
power-ups ezb zahlen wenn man die
campaign
ihr seht schon da kann man entweder
inter oder start drücken wir machen das
ganze jetzt mal alleine on money and
storage soll hast du am hyundai und hier
ist die story sometimes we will continue
und das ganze mal die karte da soll ich
denke mal amerika darstellen weil links
in amerika zum besten ort 1150 dollar
okay wir starten die mission ab dies
gilt ab
dieses upgrade feuerwehr da sich die
skills wir können jetzt einfach
losfahren
es tut mir leid wenn es an manchen
stellen bisschen ruckeln pc ist nicht
sogar so den haben erstmal becker
newcrest zweimal environment kinder da
hab ich ja zum beispiel 40 dollar
bekommen
zuletzt hatte ein freund diese diese
sachen die brown hätte man so müssen
deswegen muss man das ganze ein bisschen
abpassen versucht jetzt mal panel und
jetzt bietet total bis gilt 15 - und
wieder 30 dollar bekommen
das ist mein gamer deswegen ist das 100
ich bin mir nicht sicher sind die mit
dem blauen darüber vielleicht ein thema
das schreiben endet das spiel mal selber
es gibt es in der alte es gibt in der
alpha version online falsche richtung
und noch ein bat die polizei
und es gibt natürlich auch andere sachen
die man da machen kann man kann zum
beispiel hier auch so treten einfach mal
oder hier so schlagen wenn man so ein
bisschen anders aus holt alter hut ist
ihr das ist nicht mehr normal wie viele
leute hier gerade um mich herum sind
habe ich denke ich mache das relativ gut
ich bin gerade nämlich der erste tarif
don't kill ja okay die mit dem grünen
daraufhin meine gang members jetzt
kriege ich nämlich so ein bisschen was
abgezogen
von meinem geld nur hier ab durch hier
rum und jetzt haben wir noch mal auf die
polizei darauf würde ich mal sagen die
sind einfach ist schon weg und ich denke
sogar dass wir gleich schon am ziel sind
ja dahin bin ich schon das ziel und dann
immer noch ein bisschen nitro weil wenn
man doppel die taste drückt dann
vielleicht ein bisschen nitro ja cool
hab ich halt echt geschafft jetzt war es
okay ich würde echt erster das hätte ich
jetzt gar nicht gedacht dass ich als
eigentlich schaffe also entschuldigung
ein bisschen ruckeln das liegt nicht am
spiel ihr könnt es wahrscheinlich alles
über spielen aber mein pc ist nicht der
beste
jetzt sehen wir natürlich die tactical
ex und das wissen wir jetzt mal mit dem
so jetzt können wir schauen dass wir
nehmen jetzt 50 prozent auf maximal 150
new york in griesheim ex manager bei 25
okay das klingt nach ist das nehme ich
jetzt auf jeden fall mal start menschen
und jetzt habe ich natürlich also ich
denke jetzt fahren wir bei nacht soweit
ich das weiß ja genau
und jetzt seht ihr schon ich hab' ich
weiß noch nicht wie man schießt ich
würde mal nähe für geht's nicht ich
schieße ich denn die schweren jungs auf
dem rechten trigger bringen wir
natürlich immer ein bisschen die leute
mir war okay ich glaube ja okay meine
munitions alle kann ich irgendwie doch
nach lage nicht okay was ist das für
eine strecke also hab ich noch nicht
gespielt hat den ersten schreck war kurz
angespielt und musste dafür bei nacht
ist aber mehr auch nicht aber ich bin
schon wieder remaining first was heißt
remaining es bleibt noch eine
springen doch alle diese rampen darüber
als jetzt nichts mehr
jetzt haben wir ihn noch polen zufahrt
bis dich auch mal und dich dich braucht
auch keiner blöding rom an ihren job ist
es alle drei menschen täglich weapons
die peoples without using weapons okay
dass andere jetzt wohl geschafft war da
schon das ziel oder war davor in die
wipfel using weapons okay ich nehme
jetzt auf jeden fall keine waffe das
heißt also nitro denke ich wird gar
nichts bringen
westwood damage increased critical
damage ich denke ich nehme einfach das
mal jetzt daten die mission ich möchte
das video nicht ganz soll anhalten wie
soll ich die denn ohne waffen
unternehmen to switch weapons okay ja
gut aber wie soll ich das denn ohne
waffen schaffen
ich kann ja dann quasi nur treten und
das sind ja waffen
hallo alter ich mache das man hier nitro
ein bisschen wie soll das denn schaffen
ohne waffen
ich glaube ich verstehe gerade einfach
diese aufgabe nicht in wirklichkeit ist
ja total einfach ein bisschen abbremsen
hier vollidiot ich wollte links an dem
auto vorbei also schon wieder luca du
drin spieler ja einer der beste tipp
kommen jetzt die zwei aber hier
vielleicht mehr intro nitro engine nitro
doch das beste gewesen so gar keinen
sinn einfach ich hab hier noch geboxt
der im auwald gescheit change the past
mama continue increased maximal hertha
und bei 15
dann mal hier und jetzt war es das
nämlich wieder weil jetzt müssen wir von
vorne anfangen das heißt wir starten
jetzt einfach die mission und müssen
jetzt quasi noch mal das erste race
machen und dementsprechend seit ist
quasi alles wieder von vorne
und ich würde sagen machen das ganze
hier noch mal eben schnell ich schieß
mal ganze eben nochmal hier als erster
schnell ab da mache ich jetzt mal eben
hier
du musst du fliegst mitteln ein kollege
ich erst mal und dich braucht man ja
erst rechtliche du bist einer der will
ich gar nicht seinem sichtfeld
jetzt kommt er natürlich auch noch
andere täuschen wie rechts an kommen
aber von links von mir soll jetzt das
hier nicht da sein und auch das schild
mit
so heute drop mein gott was ist denn das
ist ein schraubenschlüssel okay ich bin
ich gucke die ganze zeit und bei dem
waffen was der verein nehme ich nehme
jetzt mal diese axt hier
er gibt euch diese axt mal es ist ja
jetzt kommen wir einfach viele autos
gerade so ich werde jetzt mal versuchen
so ein bisschen in der kurve driften
wenn es irgendwie möglich ist
jetzt kommt er auch die polizei nicht
einmal die krise game over
ja gut ich bin jetzt irgendwie dreimal
gestorben und jetzt muss ich quasi
wieder von vorne anfangen ihr weht jetzt
ich gehe jetzt auf continue dann und
jetzt seht ihr gleich wieder weiter
karte dass ich wieder beim level 1 bin
da sehe ich bin wieder beim level heinz
freunde ich gebe auf ich bin nicht gut
in rennspielen mir macht das spiel
allerdings spaß ich hab's halt vorher
schon gespielt bevor ich das ganze
aufgenommen habe und ich verbessere mich
in solchen sachen auch wenns euch
allerdings gefallen habt und ihr mehr
von minecraft videos wollt dann schreibt
man coole spieler die kommentare was
halt sondern sondern indie game ist was
jetzt nicht irgendwie sowas wie spiel
battlefield oder spiel mehr als zehn
spiele oder noch schneller spielen das
gold in seinem rollenspiel schickt mir
einfach mal solche kleinen games
stellten auf jeden fall richtig cool
vorher dran zeigt mit einer bewertung
stadt mit 2000 baum hoch wenn die
richtig nice ihr findet einen link dazu
in der beschreibung wenn es eventuell
spielen wollt kostet nicht viel und dann
würde ich sagen
aber egal wir brauchen kein boot denn
wir haben unsere arme mir an der stelle
von rahden guten boden wurden rennbooten
rennbooten rennboot bleibt stehen bleibt
stehen
ja ja nein nein ok fahrtleiter es ist es
ist in ordnung ist in ordnung
wie hast du die mich doch alle oder die
fun immer meine richtung kommen aber ich
wette der bremst nicht mal rüberkommen
heute bin ich nicht so drauf ich lass'
ich mal weiterfahren kommen hier vom
alter der bestand aber schnell kommt ist
ihr film wird überbewertet gelaufen
einfach so ein bisschen durch einen
schönen park hier bisschen macho eine
füße